wo-handed war mace, huh?
Clements: This kind of mace
appears in, uh, 12th-century
combat artwork.
Essentially, what you've got
is just a big, iron head.
This one's, uh,
got five flanges or flutes.
This is a weapon
that relies on
sheer brute concussive force.
What we've got here
is actually the most ancient
of weapons --
a club.
-A club.
In this case,
turned into a war club.
And you have to keep in mind,
you're not just --
these knights are not just
hitting with this weapon.
They've got the weight
and the mass of that gauntlet
and those arm pieces going
with them, with the momentum.
So it's not just adding
to their striking power.
It's also going to affect
their ability
to recover the weapon --
to follow through on a strike
and bring it around.
You're going to see, some
of them are gonna be hitting,
bringing it right back,
hitting again.
Other times, they're going
to have to wind the blow up.
One thing about, uh, the weapons
you'll see in the league --
swords are all --
they were all sharp weapons
back in the day,
and they were used
for cutting.
And here, we --
we've dulled the edges.
So they still have
the concussive force,
but they're not cutting
through anybody.
This is made to scramble
your eggs inside your armor.
This is a mass weapon --
what we call a mass weapon.
Mass weapons are made
to bring the impact,
bring the force, through
the armor and crush bones.
So this'll pass force
very effectively,
more so than a sword
and the edged weapon,
which will often get dissipated
on the edge of a plate.
What kind of advantages
would I have
if I used this mace
instead of an ax?
Well, this -- this weapon
has advantages in all ranges.
At long range,
you can choke back
and you can hit somebody
as they're --
as they're closing
with you.
Or if they're pulling out,
you can get another
free hit with them.
At medium range, you can
choke up a little bit
and you can still get
a very hard hit with this.
But you can make blocks --
half-to-half blocks.
You can also
turn the head in --
do a pivoting movement,
and turn the head in.
If one of them takes
a really solid hit
to the head with this,
is he gonna be able to
recover before his opponent
gets in that second
and third hit?
Well, that's --
that's very possible,
that somebody
could get dazed.
And you get dazed with a weapon
like that, somebody --
half a second, as you know,
can take you out of the fight.
A lot of people can do
a lot of stuff in that --
in that time period.
Now, to use this weapon
properly at-range, like we said,
they've gotta choke down
to get the most out of it.
Once there's closure --
once they've closed range,
they've got to take
that double-handed grip
to get anything out
of this weapon.
They can check with it.
They can hit with the head.
They can grapple with it --
put it over the top of the head
and pull people down.